in the wake of World War two the US
government is engaged in a large number
of secret medical experiments designed
to help win the Cold War developing
techniques for mind control to create a
so-called Manchurian Candidate what is
the extent of these brainwashing
experiments how did the CIA become
involved in such far-reaching and
disturbing research in May 1953
scientists at Porton Down are
researching one of the most lethal nerve
agents known to man sarin the
experiments are conducted on military
volunteers but the young servicemen have
no idea what they are letting themselves
in for on the board there was a separate
notice typed which said in so many words
volunteers wanted to help find a cure
for the common cold by volunteering Ken
Earle becomes an unsuspecting guinea pig
in the war against the Soviets
[Music]
on May 4th at Porton down he and five
other airforce men are led into a small
room by two technicians we were told by
the two men to roll up the left sleeve
these two men then took two pieces of
material and they taped them to our
forearm
they then gave us each a respirator and
that we were not under any circumstances
to take off the respirator and the door
was sealed behind us
it was very very pokey a small building
and I thought our sins him as a gas
chamber which puts the fear of death
into you of course
this technician with a file and a
pipette went round each us and he
dripped onto this pieces of material 20
drops in two rows the clear liquid is
sarin nerve agent it is quickly absorbed
into the arm through the skin
the effects are immediate I became
absolutely toast affirming I didn't know
what sheer terror there is and being
trapped and not being able to breathe
nobody fear you can't breathe I was
sweating profusely and I now aim today
at nightmares about it
after half an hour we were released
gasping a splattering and sweating into
the open air beautiful sunny May morning
absolute bliss what a wonderful thing to
be alive the corresponding paperwork
clearly states the purpose of the
experiment is to determine the lethal
dose of sarin
after the Korean War disturbing new
intelligence reaches Washington hundreds
of American troops are still being held
captive subjected to brainwashing
experiments and then killed mind control
research back home intensifies the new
goal is to cause an individual to become
subservient to an imposed control to the
point where he will perform acts against
his will
and then have no memory of the act the
search for a real-life Manchurian
Candidate begins to produce such an
assassin
the CIA faces two main challenges how to
induce amnesia and how to program in new
behavior
in 1957 dr. Ewen Cameron an eminent
psychiatrist in Montreal believes he has
the answers Cameron applies his
techniques under the guise of normal
therapy there's a three-part technique
which started with an effort to wipe out
past patterns of behavior and this was
accomplished through the use of
particularly intensive repeated
high-level electroshocks until no more
convulsions could be elicited from a
patient Cameron then plays tape recorded
messages through helmets that are locked
to his patient's heads this psychic
driving forces them to listen to
repetitive statements for weeks on end
to program in new behavior now the final
phase was to try to wipe out all
recollection of what had happened and
that was accomplished by putting people
to sleep for 3040 days accompanied by
different kinds of cocktails of drugs
now that's not any kind of therapy
that's a brainwashing experiment
[Music]